se a efe una función continua en el
intervalo cerrado menos 2 - 1 donde efe
de menos 2 es igual a 3 ok
efe de uno es igual a 6 cuál de las
siguientes opciones es garantizada por
el teorema del valor intermedio y bueno
incluso antes de ver esto
recordemos que sabemos acerca del
teorema del valor intermedio bien si
recuerdas vas a ver que lo podemos
aplicar justo aquí porque tenemos una
función continua
un intervalo cerrado en el intervalo
cerrado menos 21 y además sabemos cuánto
vale la función en menos 2
efe - 2 es igual a 3 y también sabemos
cuánto vale la función en uno la función
en uno vale 6 así que si esto no es
familiar para ti te invito a que vean
los vídeos del teorema del valor
intermedio en la canaca demint ya que el
teorema del valor intermedio nos dice lo
siguiente que si tenemos una función
continua en un intervalo cerrado
entonces la función deberá tomar cada
valor entre los valores de los extremos
del intervalo o tal vez otra forma de
decirlo no sea la siguiente para
cualquier l
entre 3 y 6
entre 3 y 6 hay al menos un aseo hay al
menos unas en el intervalo cerrado este
que tengo aquí
el intervalo cerrado menos 2 a 1
tal qué
y aquí viene lo importante tal que fm dc
sea igual a esta él es que esto sale del
teorema del valor intermedio en un
lenguaje coloquial lo único que está
diciendo es mira si tengo una función
continua que voy a dibujar por aquí en
un segundo si tengo una función continua
es decir una función continua es aquella
donde al dibujarla no puedo despegar el
lápiz entonces esta función tendría que
tomar cada valor entre 3 y 6 o dicho de
otra manera hay al menos un punto en
este intervalo hay al menos un punto en
este intervalo que toma cualquier valor
entre 3 y 6 el que tú quieras y esto
tiene mucho sentido porque nos
despegamos el lápiz entre 3 y 6 vamos a
dibujar nuestra función así que veamos
cuáles de estas respuestas cumplen con
esto que estoy diciendo y se observa
aquí dice
s es igual a 4 así que en este caso él
es igual a 4 y entonces diríamos para
cualquier 4 bien entre 3 y 6 hay al
menos una se en el intervalo menos 21
tal que fcc es igual a l hay al menos
una se entre 3 y 6 no no no espera hasta
aquí vamos bien
fcc es igual a 4 para al menos algunas c
pero tenemos que estar entre menos 2 y
un hombre porque ese es un valor de x
así que se debe de estar en este
intervalo cerrado y aquí el 3 y el 6 en
definitiva no están en ese intervalo 10
más para que me entiendas mejor voy a
tratar de dibujarlo por aquí esto voy a
tratar de dibujar esto que está diciendo
el teorema del valor intermedio para que
lo veas de una mejor manera si por aquí
tengo mí
que me deja no tenerlo por aquí por aquí
tengo
james voy a suponer que es este de aquí
y por aquí tengo mi eje x lo voy a poner
justo así y bueno voy a decir que este
es mi eje y este es mi eje x y déjame
decidir que aquí me tomo valores entre
-2 y 1 así que por aquí tengo menos 2
por aquí tengo menos 10 y 1 me voy a
fijar en este intervalo y bueno estamos
entre 36 entonces supongamos que por
aquí tengo al 3 no tengo la misma escala
pero bueno lo puedo suponer y entonces
por aquí tengo al 6 lo que me dice el
teorema del valor intermedio es que si
me fijo en este intervalo cerrado menos
2,1 estoy desde aquí hasta acá tengo
este intervalo cerrado ok
por otra parte yo sé que efe - 2 es
igual a 3 la voy a poner con este color
efe
2 es igual a 3 estamos como por aquí y
por otra parte hace que f 1 es igual a 6
estamos como por aquí y tengo una
función continua en ese intervalo déjame
ponerlo con este color entonces tenemos
una función continua entre 3 y 6 meses
que dar con este de aquí y lo que me
dice el teorema del valor intermedio mal
observemos que es lo que está pasando
aquí bueno lo que me dice el teorema del
valor intermedio es que para cada
entre 3 y 6 entre 3 y 6 no sean tomate
un valor por ejemplo este de aquí
entonces existen al menos un hace al
menos una se que toma ese valor cuando
le aplicamos la función es decir aquí
tenemos a cm y llegamos a este valor el
m donde fcc m
es igual a él y dice al menos una l
porque puede ser que no se te tomes este
valor de aquí y este de aquí y te
encuentres con este con este y veas que
tienes dos es entonces en este caso
tendrías una c y otras en esta de aquí
supongamos esto de aquí tal es que te
den este valor de l pero lo que sí
sabemos es que hay al menos unas en que
observan que sean es un valor de x se
están entre -2 y menos 1 mientras que l
tiene que estar entre 6 y 3 no podemos
estar más allá de 6 ni más abajo de 3 no
observa solamente estamos aquí así que
veamos si nos fijamos en la primera
opción
fcc es igual a 4 bueno 4 está entre 6 y
3 recuerda es el valor de l
así que supongamos que este es mi valor
de 4 ok
si nos fijamos llegamos justo aquí aquí
tenemos a este valor de ce y si observas
se cae entre menos 2 y 1 entonces aquí
tenemos el valor de 4 y se tiene que
estar entre menos 2 y 1 y aquí está el
problema para el menos algunas m entre 3
y 6 quién sabe qué pasa entre 3 y 6
recuerda si nos fijamos por acá tenemos
al 2 por acá tenemos al 3 estamos mucho
más allá de este intervalo y de hecho no
podemos saber qué es lo que está pasando
con la función entre 3 y 6 solamente
sabemos qué es lo que pasa con la
función entre menos 2 y 1
es por eso que esta no es mi opción
correcta y como no es una opción
correcta la voy a cancelar ok ahora
fcc igual a 0 muy bien veamos qué es lo
que pasa aquí fcc igual a 0 en este caso
l vale cero y estamos cayendo aquí y se
observa no podemos caer ahí porque está
fuera de nuestro intervalo 36 entonces 0
en definitiva no está entre 3 y 6 por lo
tanto ya no importa qué es lo que vaya a
pasar después porque no es el caso que
queremos entonces también puedo cancelar
en este caso
fcc igual a cero él no puede ser cero
porque es cero no está entre 3 y 6
también puedo cancelar este caso y me
queda esta última opción que dice
fcc es igual a 4 regresamos el caso
donde l vale 4 l vale 4 ok está entre 3
y 6 para al menos unas m
entre menos 2 y 1 recuerdan se caen
entre -2 y 1 así que en efecto estamos
justo aquí
va a ser nuestra respuesta correcta
porque l
cae entre 3 y 6 y se cae entre menos 2 y
1 y bueno yo pude haber dibujado de
muchas formas de esta función se me
ocurre que puede haber dibujado una
función donde tomemos muchos valores
este valor de 4 algo así si observas en
este caso cuando tomamos el valor de 4
tenemos uno de ellos tenemos otro de
ellos y tenemos por acá otro de ellos
pero todas esas se caen entre -2 y uno o
inclusive puede haber hecho una recta
algo más o menos así observa no puede
haber hecho algo así y después al vacío
porque no tendríamos una función
continua
no podemos tener discontinuidad es así
que tenemos que tener una función
continua y no soltar el lápiz llegamos a
este punto tengo una recta y bueno si
tuviéramos por ejemplo en este caso aquí
puedes ver que tenemos al menos unas en
aquí tendríamos el valor de las que
estamos buscando y ésta se vuelve a caer
entre menos 2 y 1 así que ya está esta
es mi respuesta correcta que está
garantizada gracias al teorema del valor
intermedio